faut surtout pas que la caméra bouge les
pauses à la rage ça va tout se passe
bien bon je vous emmène aujourd'hui on
est chez sur un rouge stop on pourra
voir un nouveau smartphone de shinobi
c'est cette petite bête la sas et
l'humidité pro alors y aura trois
nouveaux smartphones le ministère me
disent tu es pro et le midi slight est
dernière avec le la gamme mis neuf en
tout cas mis neuf départs dont elia
shiomi avait fait un carton plein
smartphones qui avait plutôt bien marché
là il renouvelle
on monte un peu en gamme au niveau du
processeur on passe sur un qualcomm
snapdragon et 65 je vais expliquer
l'histoire on va aller voir yann qui le
country manager de chez ubifrance il
faut nous en dire plus et nous expliquer
un petit peu laden parce que c'est vrai
qu'avec tous ces produits scion vite et
bien à force on finit vraiment par s'y
perdre et y avoir du mal à avoir un peu
de visibilité et de lisibilité sur la
gamme n'est pas le mec qui bosse ça m'a
tellement manqué devant vos tronches
même avec hamas était beau par contre la
difficulté c'est ça le point sur ta tête
mais je connais pas que c'est un visage
attention les paris c'est encore comment
ça va tu trouve bien bas ça va ça va
très bien et est en train d'être très
bon train de prendre en photo avec un
samsung
oui c'est pas plus fort tu m'as manqué
manger du vannes oc et le moc et n'a pas
changé et est toujours aussi beau
attention j'en appelle à nos mamans
allô maman laisse pas vous expliquer en
quelques mots de quoi sont proposés ces
nouveaux smartphones de shiomi
effectivement trois nouveaux smartphones
c'est cool c'est tout noté lagon je
viens de le connaître je ne connais pas
tous par coeur dont six jeux mes yeux
qui plonge là ne vous inquiétez pas
comme je vous le disais caméra
principale au niveau du modèle prôné une
caméra de 8 mégapixels
j'ai pas tout la fiche technique on
verra plus tard on en reparlera en
restera donc je vous invite à venir vous
abonner c'est pas du tout cas comme ça
vous serez tous quand on testera quand
on arrive sur le modèle qui n'est pas un
modèle professionnel on est sur la
caméra de 64 mégapixels alors ils nous
mettent en avant vraiment tout un côté
pour les créatifs au niveau de la
création c'est bien photos que vidéo ça
on le verra lors du test
c'est plutôt intéressant on pouvoir
faire de la vidéo jusqu'en vicat et
extraire des photos 30 3 mégapixels de
vos vidéos lucas beau
pourquoi pas je ne suis pas sûr
qu'aujourd'hui c'est vraiment ce qu'on
vient le chercher là dessus mais en tout
cas il vient de montrer un peu les
muscles et ce qu'ils sont capables de
faire donc why not ça fonctionne ça
vaille and sales et à wigan toi tu es
country manager de xiaomi en france oui
tout est bien j'ai pas dis des bêtises
sa sortie a pas vous avez sorti trois
nouveaux produits que vous annoncez
amideast et me disent tu es promet des
states tu peux me situer la gamme t pour
2010 est invariante la série me disent
donc six mois plus tard maintenant sept
mois plus tard la sortie le midi donc
maintenant c'est le trop frères
n'existait prometis témérité l'aide qui
arrive dans le but on va remonter
démocratiser la partie 5 j'ai aussi le
chercher leur rapport qualité prix
encore plus agressifs
oui par rapport à certaines concessions
ont été faites mais on propose vraiment
des projets très compétitif sur le
marché pour le consommateur lambda qui
arriveraient pas vendre la lisibilité
entre midi timidité c'est quoi la grosse
différence au niveau de l'adn mitis
c'était un produit on cherchait des
concessions c'est vraiment que on a fait
le produit le tout ce qu'on sait faire
savoir faire technologique chez chami et
me disent tu es c'est vrai qu'on a fait
la concession sur le
certaines parties mais d'autres partis
comme le col comme 1865 les meilleurs
processeurs du moment une talla et c'est
et qui peut aussi adapter à cette
fréquence possible pour s'y adapter
notre situation extra c'est vraiment que
ça monte qu' il est encore plus comment
dire accessible n'existait que le midi
on a ici un écran lcd 6,67 pouce pour
les deux en écran plat avec un taux de
rafraîchissement qui va jusqu'à 144
hertz alors ça commence à se développer
on a vu beaucoup de 120 hertz cette
année l'année dernière c'est 90 r cela
le 144 hertz arrive c'est pas le premier
constructeur à en proposer
mais bon pourquoi pas en tout cas il se
positionne vraiment tant qu'entreprise
extrêmement agressif avec un taux de
rafraîchissement très élevé qui va
vraiment bien vous apporter de la
fluidité lorsque vous allez jouer à des
jeux
lorsque vous allez venir scrollé sur les
réseaux sociaux donc l'expérience va
être maximisée pourquoi pas adaptatif ça
veut dire que lorsque votre jeu où j'en
sais rien le nex est que du 90e et bien
vous aurez du 90 hier et lorsque vous
vous aurez du 60 hertz et bien vous
n'aurez que du 60 hertz ça va permettre
de venir économiser de la batterie parce
que plus vous allez augmenter tout
rafraîchissements et plus à venir puiser
de l'énergie et moi votre smartphone va
durer dans le temps enfin en termes
d'énergie de batterie voilà un petit peu
l'idée donc ça il faut le savoir
pourquoi quand le choix du lcd et pas de
l'amoled c'est une question coup ce cd
choix stratégiques par rapport à
consentir un tarif bien positionné je
crois que la raison principale sont
rarement sur la partie tahri et loin
d'être élitiste et l'été cet état rythme
je sais pas c'est vrai c'est créer
pourquoi t on sait pas non il ya
beaucoup de si on laisse le mystérieux
pour le web les gens deviennent à ce
qu'ils veulent y en a un petit turbo
tentant ce tarif jamais 30 ans à terre
dans mieux ya beaucoup de traductions
possibles
finalement ce chacun s'y adaptent comme
saveurs comme leurs besoins et quand
elle cédait tu me disais bon allez écran
splitté c'était un choix d'abord que
c'est mieux pour nous d'essayer
d'adapter le 144ème way pour s'y adapter
tant gratter sur le sept scénarios
possibles ça c'est le premier
toi deuxième chose bien évidemment c'est
sur le
le tarif est si on fait un amoled tout
plat parce que beaucoup de mes fans nous
reproche qu'on a besoin d'un écran
incurvé tout ça ah ben là toute la c'est
ça coûte cher pour ce que c'est mais
finalement outre pas tous les avantages
on a ici au niveau de la performance ce
qui se fait de mieux quelque chose près
c'est le qualcomm sa dragonne 865 vous
dis à quelque chose près parce qu'elle
une mise en 65 plus qui est sorti mais
le 865 fait très très bien la faire on a
8 gigas de ram la techno c'est de la
lpddr2 5 ce qui se fait de mieux
aujourd'hui on a 8 gigas de ram sur le
modèle pro en asie' giga de ram sur le
modèle tu es un petit peu plus standard
la techno c'est aussi la dernière qui
marche très bien c'est lui ai fait trois
points c'est cool on est une très grosse
batterie de 5 millions et surtout demain
bloc de charge de 33 watts qui inclut à
l'intérieur alors il yad'autres techno
qu'une techno qui s'appelle mmt qui va
venir améliorer la charge sera 17 % plus
rapide que si vous aviez un chargeur un
peu plus standard équivalent en 33
matchs c'est un peu l'histoire ou un
smartphone
5 j'ai bien évidemment vous avez un
corning gorilla glass 5
ça c'est cool qui va se situer au pin et
la recherche si je commence à perdre les
smartphones de près vous avez un peu
remué gorilla glass 5 à l'arrière à
l'avant mais également au niveau des
caméras ici qui vient vraiment le
protéger c'est pas le dernier
corning gorilla glass le dernier c'est
le 7 mai le 5 très bien fera très très
bien la faire et vous n'avez pas de
problème là dessus ce qui est sympa
c'est que vous avez un petit capteur
d'empreintes digitales sur le côté là
comme ça vous le prenez vous posez votre
doigt ça reconnaît votre doigt ça
sécurise un guide rouge s'est placé sur
le bouton on off c'est cool on a à
l'arrière 1-3 caméra dans tout ça on se
le regardera un peu plus tard on a une
petite caméra de celle ci qui est
planqué ici là dans la petite petite
bulle et alors il ya des techno qui ont
été mises en place pour rendez vous
pouvez filmer d'un point de vue logiciel
avec les deux caméras en même temps en
vertical en horizontal tout ça comme je
vous le disais pour les créatifs donc ça
c'est assez rigolo je trouve ça plutôt
bien
pareils vous avez deux micros un à côté
à l'autre pour venir sur des prises de
sons à 360° toujours dans l'idée de la
création ça c'est bien pourquoi est un
consommateur devrait acheter le ministre
au vu d'un autre produit ou de xiaomi où
la concurrence
je pense que ça parte d'abord celle là
coupât religieux tout confort là pour
s'y retrouver la fréquence est apte à la
situation affirme 7 224 trimming s'être
entre 60 qui s'est adaptée par man a
tout même le compare du raid scrollé sur
l'installera non on voit la différence
visuellement je pense important protéger
les yeux et tout ça et deuxièmement
c'est vraiment la performance donc une
puce qualcomm et 1125 qui est aussi être
un processeur compétitifs ici un an ou
deux ans ça reste quand même un achat
deux avertissements étaient assez
rentable et après ça après c'est la
partie photo à legata botte de revoir
des gens vrais ouais ouais mais toi ça
va ça va
il est bien téléphone je vous allez
parler de mon masque c'est quoi l'avis
de l'expert de frandroid belle je trouve
beau ouais je trouve assez beau l'écran
plat j'aime bien aussi qu'il a pris
corps et pas trop voir les border un
petit peu convaincant leur semble à
l'extérieur mais ça ça a l'air d'aller
et niveau en main il est plutôt cool
voilà voilà où on en passe et prendre et
en termes de tarifs le ministe et c'est
un smartphone qui coûte 499 euros dans
la config si giga de ram 128 jia du
stockage tandis que le modèle pro coûte
599 ailleurs 100 euros de plus dans la
config du giga de ram plus 256 go de
stockage vous pourrez retrouver chez vos
opérateurs
c'est une grosse nouveauté chez shiomi
on peut retrouver enfin de smartphones
chez les trois opérateurs historiques
que sont bouygues telecom orange et sfr
ça c'est cool mais également chez fnac
darty boulanger et dès que ce sera
possible et bien je vous mettrai les
liens de la description soit dans cette
vidéo soit dans la vidéo test qui
arrivera un peu plus tard et ça
smartphone qui sera surtout disponible
enfin des smartphones qui seront
disponibles à partir du 26 octobre donc
ça c'est cool
ou est-ce que vous aurez aujourd'hui au
mit en france on a passé un cap le
peintre de 3 millions
deux français qui ont acheté en mars
conditions me tend la main c'est un cas
pour nous va c'est important ça veut
dire que la partie l'introduction est
fini maintenant faut aller chercher le
démocratiser encore plus aller chercher
parce qu'on est quand même 65 ans de
procès en france qu'on peut aller
chercher le plus de faire connaître la
marque dire aux gens que la marque n'est
crédible et la qualificative externe est
pas
on est en a pas fini le boulot être que
la crise sanitaire elle vous a impacté
où étaient les besoins pacte encore
passé sera terminé oui mais en fait la
plupart de nos emplois y sont déjà
reste à la maison pour certaines
fonctions qui peuvent faire le même
efficacité en télétravail
ils sont déjà et que pour l'instant
aucune personne chez nous qu'ils étaient
douchés après si par exemple les
magasins un deuxième confinement qui
peuvent rappeler par le gouvernement et
serra si le magasin est fermé c'est sûr
qu'elle en fait aux recteurs de pro
l'instant juste
des collègues au bureau ça va ok tu
perds ta mère fille merci à toi et puis
un modèle light avec un capteur de 64
mégapixels à l'arrière d'un aura
d'autres et il fallait publier pas plus
d'infos tout de suite à l'instant où ce
fait cette vidéo dispose en trois
couleurs le bleu l'or et puis le gris un
écran avec un taux de rafraîchissement
de son mariage pour ça c'est aussi
vachement intéressant une grosse
batterie de 4800 20 millions terreur
niveau puissance niveau performances on
a un instinct dragonne 7 155 g g pour
gainey un smartphone 5 g certes wade
dernier soc de qualcomm dans la série 7
donc plutôt cool et qui est dispo à 299
euros dans la version 6 giga de ram 64
géant du stockage disponible en cent
mille store et sur me.com et puis vous
avez la version 6 giga de ram 128 go de
stockage à 329 euros
dispo un petit peu partout chez vos
opérateurs et dans le commerce bon ça
c'est cool et dispo à partir du 26
octobre
alors je suis on me présente d'autres
produits que je ne connais pas que je
n'ai pas tout de suite vu qu'il vient
d'être révélée lors la conférence de
presse qui a eu lieu juste avant je sais
qu'à une monde connecté et d'autres
produits donc voila moi je trouve plutôt
intéressant ces produits je fais un
petit tour de jeu dofus technique voir
si j'ai rénové je prends je vous ai à
peu près tout dit
l'idée c'est vraiment sain c'est la
création c'est l'accent sur la photo sur
la vidéo l'expérience multimédia
complètement maximiser un smartphone
performant un smartphone endurant voilà
la promesse que nous fait aujourd'hui
chez omis avec ces mid east et cette
série mythique doit vous ce que vous en
pensez en bas en commentaire perso je
trouve ça bien on est dans l'idée est
toujours de shiomi de ce qu'ils savent
faire
ils sont une fois de plus très présent
ils sont très agressifs dans les tarifs
la voilà donc à voir à tester sur le
principe c'est cool et on en reparle
d'ici quelques jours vous envoie
beaucoup d'amour depuis toits de paris
pour lé soin de vous et à très vite
ciao
cela